le phénomène de la corruption est de
plus en plus révélé et çaavère être un
véritable outil des trafics de
stupéfiants mais j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure c'est un outil plus globalement
de la criminalité organisée puisque de
toute façon les trafics de stupéfiants s
s sont compris dans un ensemble plus
large que celui de la criminalité
organisée sans la corruption qu'elle
soit publique ou privée les trafics ne
prospèrent pas ça peut toucher bien
évidemment des personnels dans les ports
et les aéroports qui vont faciliter le
passage de la marchandise ou le ou ou la
sortie du produit de d'un port ou d'un
d'un aéroport ça peut toucher des agents
publics des policiers des gendarmes des
douaniers des greffiers aucune aucune
profession n'est épargnée euh dès lors
que vous avez des euh des des
trafiquants qui offrent des sommes
d'argent extrêmement conséquentes vous
pourrez avoir à un moment donné des
personnels qui qui vont répondre à
l'appel à l'appel de de ces sirènes
criminelles
[Musique]